what's going on reject nation greg and
john here we got
ourselves a final trailer for zack
snyder's justice league a couple of
things i wanted to mention before we go
into this
one i am sorry for being late to this
completely my fault what you guys don't
know is i'm supposed to be going out of
town booked this trip a few months ago
uh looking at wedding venues from march
28th to april 2nd so right now
we're trying to get like a week ahead in
our patreon we put up like two videos a
day on youtube which takes a few hours
and we also spend several hours a day
filming and editing for patreon i'm
trying to get a week ahead there so that
way that's all covered the week we're
gone right now we're not even a day
ahead
so earlier today my skin was just
flaring up and i had like a big headache
so i'm sorry for being late to this but
i didn't want to shoot this feeling like
oh no
i'm kind of out of it right now secondly
uh we might actually be
getting a screener for this movie it
remains to be seen but we might be the
final press to see it uh
slightly a man named benafleck
contacting me yeah yeah
directly by text just like what's up g
it's b you want to screen the movie come
to me
venom of course want to carve out like a
comfortable five hours to make sure we
can
properly talk about it afterwards and
you know uh i don't want to be like
filming it
tired it's four hours long right right
weird chunks we want to do it pure you
know yeah exactly
exactly full leg watch longs will be at
the patreon for that anywho let's do
this guys
[Music]
oh we'll see we'll get jl two and three
i've never seen a being as strong
looking so sharp maybe one
we need superman
[Music]
i spent a lot of time trying to divide
us now you gotta unite us
i made a promise to him on his grave
i need to bring us together
there are enemies coming from far away
they serve an old power i can't wait to
watch this
they're killing the watch this world is
divided
[Music]
lanterns
[Music]
let's go let's go
i have a second chance this is like the
man's steel trailer
yeah build-up
would never come again
fighting the devil in his army
ah
oh
what was that
what was that at the end something
darker
assuredly
why was martha kent's eyes all lit up
hold on it's her turn to do the savings
right before
oh damn look at this one shot here i
didn't even properly notice cyborg's
face is getting like obliterated here
it's actually going to reverse it looks
like flash is repairing the closer he
gets his skin's
coming back together oh [ __ ]
she green gg martian man
harry linux has martha kent
is that what's going on here that'll be
the only thing that makes sense to me
is that she's martian manhunter that
would be an interesting way to pull that
right that that kind of i mean but how
long would she have been martian bannon
is the in this movie because i'm
assuming this is
a scene for when she goes to visit lois
yeah
um she's not kurt tony we know that the
only
logical explanation would be that's
martian manhunter in disguise again
that's what he does
yeah yeah i mean like it would make a
lot i'm sure there's a scene
of context maybe of him choosing to do
this so it's maybe not as flummoxing in
the actual movie itself but if that
becomes the twist that just like there's
a martha kent presence that it turns out
to be martian manhunter the whole time
i i guess i would be a little bit like
this is an odd way to
introduce this a little bit because it
just ties into yeah so many other
heavy contexts from the past well i feel
like she i don't think she'd be martian
man under the whole time i think just
for this particular occasion of visiting
because there's a scene where she goes
to visit lois lane yeah so i'm
maybe that's actually in the zack
center's original vision
it just doesn't look like a dream
sequence no yeah
i feel like that's what it is the eyes
look like martian manhunter eyes hold on
a sec
i literally type in martian man
everything on google is
look at martian managers martha cannot
those are actually the top stories i
just wanted to get a photo of
the martian man underneath apparently
this is already a big thing
um that's on top oh crap late to that
that
took up most of my my viewing experience
up let's watch this trailer again
[Music]
that upper lip you know that scene was
fun in the that other cut but
this looks like a painting this whole
thing looks like a painting
together
there are enemies coming from far away
they serve an old power
this world is divided
no protectives here no lanterns
no kryptonium remember we were all
freaking out about that line
yeah no lanterns
to dusk of existence
shall be mine
shall be
i have a second chance
you know there's there's been like early
reviews i've been releasing for this
and a lot of them are incredibly
positive
social in media reactions
no you know that atlantis is going to be
great
demons has fallen how many hells he's
never fought us
united
this is the coolest aquaman has left in
any of these absolutely like the most
like grippingly badass fight
more than just like a guitar solos worth
the bet
oh the final like couple hours of this
is going to be insane
look at those superman shots man oh they
are
so good cool even that just that shot
looking up i know we've seen it a bunch
but i love that of just them looking out
at the dawn of justice something tells
me this will be the most
accurately felt tonally of them all
it seems like it would have the most
fully realized tone like this just leads
with like a confidence but it's also
very steady
and deliberate dark somber still
harrowing you feel like a legacy on
display here you feel
you feel like legend it feels heroic
still
you know i think this is this is the
best one best trade of them all
absolutely it feels like it's in slow-mo
without a lot of it actually being in
slow motion
yeah i mean all the trailers have been
so good but this is my favorite yeah
yeah it really does feel like an
epic clash of like you know we were
talking about in the last video like of
lord of the rings scale proportions but
then crashed into
you know justice league scale
proportions yeah you know sci-fi
fancy fantasy you know you can't do this
kind of movie
in two hours no you can't this has to be
four hours i rewatched uh
wonder woman last night so i wanted to
do like my watch of all the ones that
were supposed to be the proper
other i skipped suicide squad but i
wanted to do the why
i want the air to cut i'm putting that
out there i do want that haircut hashtag
really
hashtag i do want that but i didn't
bother to re-watch that other one but i
watched man of steel bvs ultimate
edition
and wonder woman just so ready for it
now like i'm just so ready for it
i'm so i can't i'm i feel like i'm gonna
cry and i haven't even seen it feel like
i really gotta change when we did that
dc eu ranking video
we can update it that i felt like i was
we were going off of memory of the last
time we saw these
yeah and i saw some of these again too
oh you know what it's actually like i
prefer this one way more
i'm excited for the superman arc as well
like everyone just looks like they're
having a clear-cut
character arc here yeah and everybody
looks equally important to the
story you know everybody feels featured
equally in this trailer as part of this
overarching struggle you know it's like
you feel that sense of we're gonna try
to handle as much of this as we can but
we need an ace in the hole and we need
superman right now yeah
we've talked so much about this yeah but
this is and then we're about to talk so
much more about that which we actually
watch it
like this is just the tip of an iceberg
because while people have been like i
stopped releasing so much footage i'm
like it's
it's a four-hour movie it's a four-hour
movie how can you possibly spoil it yeah
yeah
it's like it's one thing to release a
lot of footage from an hour and 45
minutes worth but you know like this is
way girthier but that's the beautiful
thing about like a
extended zack snyder film where when
zack snyder films get to breathe is the
beauties and the details
the beauties and the actual like rhythm
and slow pace and
there's little nuances here or there
versus
like trying to trim him down yeah
because then you can really see where
the tlc goes
it's strange to be like it's four hours
but i'm ready to eat it up let's see
here
all right
oh [ __ ] we got ourselves a screener
speak of the devil last ones baby we did
it we did it all right
we made the i we made the cut i didn't
want to take a nap
we made the snyder tonight i think i can
let's see if we can do this today and
then have it out
you know take a take a four hour nap
tomorrow
oh [ __ ] yeah oh pressure's on get this
done
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button and honestly we
wouldn't be in a position to even get an
opportunity like this it wasn't for your
support so thank you